all right welcome to the future of Life
Institute podcast I'm back here with
Connor Leahy and Connor is of course the
CEO of conjecture Ghana welcome to the
podcast back again all right so how does
the Strategic landscape of AGI look like
right now tell me if tell me if you
think this kind of structure is is
approximately true do you have open Ai
and deepminded front
followed by the American Tech giants
like Apple and Google and meta and then
perhaps you have American startups and
then you have Chinese Tech Giants and
startups in terms of capabilities is
that the right ordering sort of I would
say deepmind is behind open EI by a
pretty significant margin right now uh I
think anthropic might actually be ahead
of deepmind at this point
um not 100 clear deep mine keeps the
cards much closer to the chest so it
might have some really impressive
Eternal things I've heard some things
that effect but I don't have evidence of
them so it seems to be open AI is clear
front center ahead of everyone else I
expect anthropic will catch up it seems
like they're trying very hard to train
their gbt4 model right now like the
equivalent model right now I expect they
will succeed Tech Giants I mean really
depends like meta is like pretty far
behind Google is deepmind
um Apple doesn't do anything as far as I
can tell so I would for example Apple
thinks of startups such as character are
ahead of all of them like character AI
is a company that was founded by name
Shazier and others you know Shazier
being the person who invented the
Transformer
and you know they're they're both
focused on chat Bots and such but their
models are quite good they're quite good
so they're yeah they're yeah that's kind
of
how it was set yeah I don't feel that
Chinese check science and startups are
very relevant I think they're really far
behind and I don't expect them to catch
up anytime soon are we simply waiting
for the tech American Tech Giants to
make moves here I I mean apple has a lot
of money they have a lot of talent they
have machine learning chips on all of
their iPhones you could you could easily
see an enhanced Siri uh GPT 4 style sure
but you know Google which is supposed to
be the best of these couldn't even keep
the guy who invented Transformers around
because they're so dysfunctional then
one of the first things I was you know I
was told by experienced investors and
such when I found the startup is that
like incumbents are not competition
they're all incompetent it's like all
like
sure all these things are possible they
have the resources to do these things
but there is a lot of reasons why it
could be very hard for large
organizations to execute on these kinds
of things another great example is The
Bard so like the chatbot that Google
produced
um it was severely delayed it you know
had lots of problems and it was just
like extraordinarily underwhelming
compared to what a much smaller group at
openai was capable to do in smaller
amounts of time you know Google is in
code red now where you know the CEO is
personally involved and like everyone's
freaking out and they
that doesn't mean they can catch up like
you know just because a lot of people in
a board room say something should be
done and they have a lot of money that's
not enough it's there are some things
that are actually hard and you know
training complex cognitive engines like
gpt4 is among those things other ones
are for example like chip production
like you know China did a huge thing
about how they're going to produce their
domestic chip production they're going
to catch up to tsmc and that has now
been like slowly like choking in a way
because it's just not succeeding because
no one in the world other than tsmc can
get these ultraviolet machines to work
for whatever reason so what we're doing
right now in kind of um describing
incumbent technology Giants as
incompetent might that be mistaken
because perhaps they're hiding they're
they're really they're not waiting to
release until they have something that's
very polished that would be very
apple-like thing to do perhaps deepmind
has something uh that they're not
releasing because they are safety
conscious or is this simply is this kind
of Wishful Thinking wishful thinking
okay so so so the situation is that this
is interesting because because then the
situation is kind of how it would look
if you're a naive Observer you're just
seeing open AI making lots of progress
and the the most legible big players are
the most advanced big players is that so
basically the the Strategic landscape is
transparent in that way it is quite
transparent like the truth of the matter
is this field is not good with secrecy
this is not like defense contractors
where people have a culture of secrecy
and like keeping things towards the
chest like apple is like the only
company on this list that like is good
at that deepmind also and traffic is
also trying but you know mixed if you
ask you know who's better you know
Lockheed Martin or like you know Airbus
fighter jets or whatever I'm like okay I
genuinely don't know like you know
that's like actually hard to know and
like people will actively make it hard
for you to know these things but like
all these people have an incentive to
make it public how good they are and
they do so quite aggressively when it
benefits them and you know Google you
know scrambled after chat EPT to catch
up with Bart and they put their best
effort forward and it was a flop and you
know same thing like with Ernie and
China and stuff like this like I think
like don't Galaxy brain yourself like
it's just what it looks like and also
the AI researchers in the most advanced
organizations they they want their they
want to publish research so that they
perhaps can can move to another
organization they have Mo they have
interests and incentives that are not uh
not particularly aligned with the
company they work for so there are these
there are these publishing Norms where
your resume as an AI researcher is your
published papers and does this make it
basically difficult to to prevent new
advances from from spreading out to to a
lot of companies yep that's exactly
correct but if that's the case why can't
Google catch up then because there is an
additional aspect to it
um which is execution and tacit
knowledge so especially with large
language model training a massive amount
would difference a good language model
from a decent language model is
weird Voodoo or it's just like
someone just has a feeling like oh you
know you have to turn down the Adam beta
to Decay parameter why
gnome said so you know like there is a
theoretical catch-up you know where it's
like you know you need to come up with
the right architecture the right
algorithms whatever but there's also
engineering like just like research and
like Logistics like you know setting up
a big compute data center is hard and
takes a lot of money and time and
specialized effort and also then you
need so there's like a logistical aspect
to it there's also there's a you know
will and like you know executive
capacity that like can an organization
commit to doing something like this and
like have someone lead it who can like
actually manage the complexities
involved with it and then there's a huge
aspect of task knowledge of just like
the stuff that isn't written down and
there's a lot that is not written down
and that that tested knowledge might be
particularly important in chip
production which could be why you know
the the Giants or the people in front
the companies in front and ship
production are you know they are very
difficult to copy that is exactly
correct like this is also what people on
the inside of Flagship production will
tell you that there is a absolutely
phenomenally large amount of tacitology
that goes into reducing high-end
computer chips and that like there's a
lot of stats down to like only tsmc has
and like they're not writing it down and
even if they wanted to they probably
couldn't why is it that for example with
defense companies or with chip
production there there's a there's a
protection of intellectual property in
in such companies that we don't see in
AI companies in the the most kind of
secure or safe uh secrecy uh in AI
companies is simply to to not say what's
happening you you don't see that that
these company secrets are protected by
intellectual property in the same way
yep I think this is completely
contingent historical cultural fact I
think there is no
it didn't have to be this way I think it
was literally just coincidence it's
literally just coincidence that just the
personalities of people that like
founded this field and like the academic
Norms that it came from a very academic
area there is much less military
involvement and much less you know
industry involvement initially and
there's much more like academics have
much more bargaining power in that like
um because of the high level of tacit
knowledge there's a larger bargaining
power that academics have here because
you know if gnome Shazier wants to
publish like he can go wherever he wants
so if you don't allow him to he'll just
go somewhere else or like whoever you
know any high profile person but I think
this is totally contingent from the
perspective of people in ml that thing
like this is the way things have always
been we'll always be can only be this is
obviously wrong because you know you're
telling me the people who build like you
know stealth Fighters are not incredible
scientists and Engineers like you know
give me a break like just because you're
a great scientist engineer doesn't mean
they're like you know compelled by their
very genomics to like you know want to
publish like no this is just a cultural
Contin this is a contingent truth about
how the culture happened to have evolved
as the race to AGI heats up will we see
more more closed Miss so close the data
closed algorithms uh would you see Labs
not publishing as many papers will these
kind of Open Source Norms from the AI
researcher Community begin to fall apart
I hope so
we're seeing some of it that's for sure
and I hope it accelerates okay as you
see it we are already in a race towards
AGI correct yep obviously so maybe 10
years ago when people were debating AI
people would debate whether human level
AI is is possible and whether we could
whether we could get there within a
couple of centuries and so on perhaps uh
is it time now to retire the the term
ATI and to talk about just specific
predictions because it's it's people
mean a lot of different things perhaps
if you if you asked Conor Leahy in 2010
whether chat GPT or gpt4 was an AGI
system what would you have responded I
mean depending on how well you described
it I would have said yes but I do think
these things are API so I still do but
just like people just don't like my
definition of the word AGI so I don't
use that word very much I agree that the
word AGI is not particularly good it's
um people use it to mean very very
different things like by reasonable
definitions of AGI that were used like
10 years ago obviously chat gpt's AGI
obviously so like most the definitions
of ATI from like 10 or 20 years ago were
you know vaguely can do some human-like
things in some scenarios right and like
you know and like you know reasonable
human love performance I'm like a pretty
wide range of task obviously attached
apt and gpt4 have reached this level and
obviously they have the ability to go
beyond that but there's other
definitions that they don't fulfill you
know like strictly better at humans at
literally everything like sure you know
TBT is not that but also LOL like what
are you doing perhaps that's not super
interesting there will always be two
percent that where humans are just
better
sure or people are just you know testing
it wrong or just not bothering to do it
or whatever so like the the real
definition of AGI that I am most
interested in personally is more vague
than that and it's something like
A system that has the thing that humans
have that chimps don't
it's like you know a thing that you know
you know human brains are basically
scaled up chimp brains you know they're
like the fact they're like three year
four or something they're all the same
structures all the same kind of things
internally blah blah blah but humans go
to the Moon gyms don't so you know
there's some people who are like oh okay
but like you know there's always gonna
be some task that A specialized you know
tool like you know AGI couldn't fold
proteins as good as Alpha fold or
whatever I'm like yeah sure sure AGI
maybe you can't fold proteins as good as
Alpha fold but it can invent Alpha fold
so the relevant thing I'm personally
interested in is just like
a thing that is powerful enough to learn
and do
science and to pose potentially
existential risks to humanity like
that's the thing I personally care about
and when I talk about AGI that's
generally what I'm referring to but I
agree it's a bad meme I think it's a bad
word because other people are as I've
said before some people in the hearing
AGI think like you know
friendly human robot buddy who's like
you know sort of smart as you but not
really smarter you know but other people
think you know AGI is god-like super
thing that can do everything log into
media things
uh yeah you know we can we can have it
and we can have a semantic fight about
this but I don't know so perhaps a way
to resolve these uh issues is to make
predictions
do you would you be willing to to make a
prediction about when for example a an
academic paper created by an AI model
would get published in say a a
reasonably high quality scientific
journal that's under defined it's like
does the sister how much human
intervention is allowed here do I give
it a prompt does it have to man you know
navigate the website and upload the
paper itself say you you give it a you
can give it a detailed prompt and the
system simply has to create the paper
and nothing else okay so do does this
have to have actually occurred or be
possible because possible yesterday
actually occurred I think there's no
one's gotten around to it I just don't
bother to do this do you think this
could be done now yeah absolutely like
obviously so like you know the SoCal
Affair you know already got papers
published you know you know decades ago
which complete nonsense I think you
could have done this with gbt 2 probably
if you if you allow like non-stem
journals you may maybe need gpt3 for
stem journals but like have you read ml
papers like so many of them are so awful
like
this is like not that hard so you think
this is basically already here now oh
yeah absolutely but I think this is not
capturing the thing you're interested in
this thing I think you're probably
interested in is like candidate do
science you're not interested in candid
trick reviewers into thinking something
is good so the question of when will the
publish a scientific paper which were
what I expect you know correctly if I'm
wrong expectually looking forward to
question when can it do science you're
not looking for the question how stupid
are peer reviewers true so how how can
we make this question interesting then
is it is it how when can a can an AI
system publish a scientific paper that
gets cited a lot or or is that also
simply kind of uh a way of gaming the
system or so there's various ways we can
think about this and and
I'm going to give the unsatisfying but I
think correct answer which is by the
time you can do that it's too late if
you have a system that can fulfill
whatever good criteria you can actually
come up with that actually means you can
do actual science it's too late and I
expect at that point if we have not
aligned such a system you're not
creating from things then you know end
times are upon us and we do not have
much time left if any if you ask me to
bet on these things or like you know do
you know with my real money I just like
wouldn't because I like I don't expect
the BET to pay out do you expect AIS to
publish uh credible scientific papers
before they can empty a dishwasher
credible or correct those are different
correct interesting scientific papers I
expect that to happen probably before
the dishwasher yeah I can make a
concrete prediction I expect the world
to end before you know like more than 10
of cars on the street are autonomous
okay so what what we have here is is a
scenario in which we are close to to
transformative AI we could call it uh or
perhaps deadly AI if we are very close
does this mean that the the game board
is kind of settled in a sense the big
players are the the players that are
going to take us all the way there so
for example we could ask is it open AI
that ends up creating transformative AI
seems pretty likely in the current
trajectory if nothing changes if
Government doesn't get involved if you
know culture doesn't shift if people
don't Revolt then yeah I expect you know
open AI Deep Mind anthropic eighty
percent one you know 70 one of them and
like you know let risk percentage like
smeared over you know like other actors
or like actors that have yet verged are
we are we getting hyped up on an
exponential curve that's about to
flatten off so will we for example
because we run out of data or we run out
of accessible compute or something of
that nature this is not something you
see you you see coming I don't see any
reason to expect this my general
predictions are usually predict what if
you don't know what the future is going
to hold predicted what just happened
will happen again and this is what I'm
seeing we're at the beginning of the
next you know we're now in takeoff you
know exponentials are happening and will
is flatten off at some point yeah sure I
just expect that to be post apocalypse
let's take a tour of the landscape of
the different alignment Solutions or AI
Safety Solutions so the current Paradigm
that's that's used by openai for example
is that you train on human creative data
and then you do reinforcement learning
from Human feedback kind of fine-tuning
the model afterwards if nothing changes
if we are very close to transformative
AI if it perhaps transformative AI is is
will be developed by openai could this
succeed as a as a last option do you
think that reinforcement learning from
Human feedback could take us to
something at least somewhat uh Safe
Systems no there's no chance of this
Paradigm working now like it's not it's
not even the alignment solution it's not
a proposal I don't think the people
working on it will even claim that like
I'm pretty certain that if you asked
like Paul Cristiano or something like is
our HF a solution to alignment they
would just he would just say no and for
context Paul Christiano basically
invented uh reinforcement learning from
Human feedback yet he was one of the
core people involved in it and I don't
think he I mean maybe some people
involved in the creation we're playing
this I don't know but I would expect
that if you ask the people to create
these methods is this an alignment
solution they would say no and they
don't expect this to work like I
don't think that rhf
in any way addresses any of the actual
problems of alignment it is a the core
problem of alignment
is how do you get a very complex
powerful system that you don't
understand to reliably
do something complicated but you can't
fully specify in domains where you
cannot supervise it it's you know the
principal agent problem writ large
rhf does not address this problem it
doesn't even claim to suggest this
problem there's no reason to expect that
rhf should solve this problem
this is like it's like you know clicker
training an alien you know it's like you
know
there is every time you do an early TF
update so you can you know if for those
are not familiar you kind of imagine
it's simplified as the you know the
model produces some text and you give it
a thumbs up or a thumbs down and then
you do a gradient update to like you
know make it more or less likely to the
stuff
you have no idea what is in that
gradient there is no idea what it is
learning what is updating on you know
let's say you know your model threatens
some users or whatever and you're saying
like oh that's bad so give it a thumbs
down
well what does the model learn from this
well one thing it might learn is don't
threaten users another thing you might
learn is don't get caught threatening
users or it could learn to use less
periods or you know
um don't use the word green or like like
who knows like in practice what it's
going to learn is is a superposition of
like all of these like or like
tons of these possible explanations and
it's going to you know change itself
like the minimum amount to like fulfill
this criteria or like move in that
direction
and in that domain but you have no
reason to expect this to generalize
maybe it does sure maybe it does
but maybe it doesn't like you have no
reason to expect it to there is no
Theory there is no prediction there is
no safety it is like you know it's like
the you know secreted Roy and the tiger
right it's like well you know we've
raised it from birth it's so nice and
then it mauls you like why who knows
tiger had a bad day I don't know perhaps
the counter arguments or something like
this is that it's only when we begin
interacting with these systems in an
empirical way that we can actually make
progress uh the the 10 years of
alignment research before uh say 2017
didn't really bring us any closer it was
only when when openai began uh
interacting with real systems that that
we understood how they even worked and
therefore perhaps gained information
about how to align them do you bother it
no and and because I mean like which
part of that is true like a it's the
saying that like no progress happened
when it was like you know three people
in the basement working out with no
funding is like what the hell are you
talking about a like like given it was
three people in the basement they made a
longer progress on predicting things
that would happen on de-confusing
Concepts on you know
building an ontology for things that
don't yet exist this was extremely
impressive given the extremely low
amount of effort put into this and you
know
sure they didn't like
you know they didn't solve alignment
sure but like has any progress happen
alignment since then it's like not
obvious to me that there's been more
people using the word there's a lot more
papers about it but like and like
there's stuff like Arlo Jeff and stuff I
don't consider roh actually progress in
a sense as regression it's like the fact
that anyone and this is not to meant to
be as a critique per se of the people
who did Arlo check because I think they
were fully aware that hey this is not
alignment this is an interesting thing
we want to study a little bit which I
think is totally fair so legitimate you
know and like rohf has its purpose it's
you know it's a great way to make your
product nicer right as like a
capabilities method rhf was totally fine
like you know just don't delude yourself
into thinking that this is you know I
don't
buy this whole like well if it makes
them a model behave better in some
subset of scenarios this is progress
towards alignment I think this is a
really bad way of thinking of the
problem it's like saying
well if I hide my password file two
folders deep then that is security
because you know there are some
scenarios where an attacker would not
think to look two folders deep and I'm
like
sure in like some trivial sense that's
true but like that's obviously not what
we mean when we talk about security it's
like if you if you encrypt the password
file but your encryption is bad I'm like
okay that's progress but your encryption
is bad I'm like all right cool this is
obviously safety I accept this as safety
but now I have problems with your
encryption you know system that is
progress and Alignment that we can argue
about you moving a thing your your
password.txt two folders deep I do not
consider progress you weren't even
trying to solve the problem you were
trying to do something different you
know you don't think that uh Microsoft's
Bing chat or Sydney uh was less aligned
than the chat gbt4 not in the ways I
care about like it's you I think this is
a stretching of what I use the term
alignment for so like
you can make that statement I'm this I
think this is a completely legitimate
way of defining the word alignment if
you want to Define it that way that is
an okay thing to do but it's not the
thing I care about I do not expect that
if I had an underlined existential risk
AGI and I did the chat GPT equivalent to
it that that saves you I think that
gives you nothing you die anyways nature
doesn't grade on a curve like just
because you're you know 10 better if you
don't meet the mark you still die it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter if I'm
you know your smiley face was a little
ten percent larger than the next guy's
smiley face if you're only painting you
know incrementally larger smiley faces
it doesn't matter so what about
extrapolations from reinforcement
learning from Human feedback for example
having AIS work to give feedback on
other AIS could that maybe scale to to
something that would be more interesting
for you why would you expect that to
work like where does the same safety
come from here there is no step in this
process where you actually are
addressing the core difficulty of how do
you deal with a system that will get
more smart that will reflect upon itself
that will learn more that is
fundamentally alien with fundamentally
alien goals encoded in ways we do not
understand can access or modify that is
extrapolating into larger and larger
domains that we cannot supervise no part
of this
addresses this problem it's like you can
play Shell Games with where the
difficulty is until you confuse yourself
sufficiently to thinking it's fine this
is a very common thing how does the
science all the time especially in
cryptography there's a saying everyone
can create a code complex enough that
they themselves can't break it
and this is a similar thing here where I
think everyone can create a lineman
scheme sufficiently complicated that
they themselves think it's safe but
so what like if you don't if you just
confuse where the safety part is that
doesn't actually give you safety what
would be evidence that you're wrong or
right here for example if it turns out
that the GPT model that's that's
available right now is not used to
create uh you know havoc in the world is
not used to to scam people and turns out
to to not be be dangerous in the sense
that we expected would this be evidence
that perhaps open AI is doing something
right so it a proof of this would be is
that no one on the entire internet can
find any way to make a model say
something that there's no prompt that
can be found that makes it say something
open 8 doesn't want it to say perhaps
not not say something bad it's it's not
specifically about bad words this is
actually quite important this is quite
important because what open AI is trying
to do is to stop the model from saying
bad things that's what they were trying
to make it do and they failed that's the
interesting thing if they had an
alignment technique that actually worked
that I expect might have a chance to
work on super intelligence system it
should be able to make your less Smart
Systems never in any scenario say a bad
thing so it should be much more it
should work in in almost all cases or
basically all cases foreign so
importantly it has to be all cases
because if it's not all cases then I I
unless you have some extremely good
theoretical reason why actually this is
okay but by default these are black
boxes I don't accept any assumptions
unless you give me a theory a causal
story about why I should relax my
assumptions then I'm like well if it's
breakable it will break
and this is the security mindset the
difference between security mindset and
ordinary paranoia is ordinary paranoia
assumes things are safe until proven
otherwise security mindset assumes
things are unsafe until proven otherwise
and sure you can't apply security
mindset to literally everything all the
time because you go crazy right sure but
when we're dealing with existential
threats of extremely powerful superhuman
optimizing systems systems whose whole
purpose is to optimize reality into
weird you know edge cases to to find
break systems to glitch to to you know
enforce power upon systems this is
exactly the type of system you have to
have a security mindset for because if
you have a system that's looking for a
hole in your walls you can't and that
you have one small hole that's not good
enough if you have a system which is you
know randomly probing your wall and you
have one small hole yeah maybe that's
fine if it's small enough that's okay
but it's not okay if it is the
deliberately looking for the small hole
and if it's really good at finding them
what about the the industry of cyber
security for example you would assume
that they have security mindset or at
least they should have but accidents
happen all the time data is leaked and
so on so isn't that evidence that we can
survive that we can survive situations
where we should have had security where
where there are holes in our security so
so it's not actually true that systems
have to work 100 of the time the fact
that we survived has not anything to do
with the security method it has to do
with the systems being secured not being
substantial if those systems had been
existentially dangerous hdis yes I
expect we would be dead it's only
because of the limited capabilities of
these systems that can be hacked and
then have been hacked and so on exactly
let's let's take another Paradigm of AI
safety which is mechanistic
interpretability and this is about
understanding what this black box
machine Learning System is doing trying
to reverse engineer the algorithm that
produced the neural network weights is
this is this a a hopeful Paradigm in
your opinion I think it's definitely
something worth it worth working on is
something that you know meeting people
at conjecture work on as well I think
the way I think about interpretability
is not as res as a alignment agenda like
alignment like interpretability doesn't
solve alignment it might give us tools
with which we can't construct an align
system it might allow us like the way I
I think about in my ontology is that I
think of mechanistic interpretability as
attempting to move cognition from Black
Box neural networks into white boxes
again as I've said before black box is
Observer dependent you know neural
networks are not inherently black box
it's not like an inherent property of
the territory it's property of the map
if you have extremely good
interpretability in your head an
extremely good theory and extremely you
know a lot of compute in your head and
whatever then a neural network would
probably look like a white box to you
and if that is the case fantastic now
you can like you know bound lots of
things and maybe like stop it from doing
bad things and what whatever and so I
expect this so this is like like this is
the default thing I tell people to do if
they don't know what to do if they're
like I don't know what to do with oh I
meant or saved it I'm just like okay
just working interpretability just like
just like try just like just like bash
your head against it and just see what
happens
um not because I think it's easy I
expect this to be very hard I also think
a lot of the current Paradigm
mechanistic interpretability is not
great I think a lot of people are making
simplifying assumptions I think they
should be making but
um in general I'm in favor and I think
this is good it's one problem or perhaps
the main problem with interpretability
research is just the question of whether
it can move fast enough so we are just
beginning to understand the some
interesting clusters of neurons in in
dpt2 but right now gbt 5 is being
trained and so can it keep up with the
pace of progress do you think it can I
mean the same implies to like literally
every other thing my my default answer
is no I don't expect things to go well
like again I expect things to go poorly
I do not expect us to solve alignment on
time I expect things will not slow down
sufficiently I expect things will
continue and expect us to die I expect
this is the default outcome of the
default world we are currently living in
this doesn't mean it has to happen there
is this
important thing that you know the world
being the way it is is not over
determined it didn't have to be this way
the way the world currently is the path
we're currently on
is not determined by God it is because
of decisions that humans have made
individual humans have made decisions
and institutions and so on have made
decisions and you know done things in
the past that have led us to the moment
we aren't right now this was not over
determined it didn't have to be this way
it doesn't have to continue to be this
way but it will
if nothing changes
so I exp do I explain interpretability
to work on time no do I expect tell them
to work on time no do we expect rlgf to
work ever no I don't expect any of these
things to work that doesn't mean it's
impossible if we take action if things
change if we slow down or if we make
some crazy breakthroughs or whatever I
think I think interpretability is like I
think there is a lot that can be done
here you know I think there's a lot of
theory there's a lot of you know things
that can be done here
will they happen in will they have like
are they possible to happen yes will
they happen in time
probably not then there is the research
done by Paul Cristiano and Eli
isaacowski at the alignment resource
center and the Machine intelligence
Research Institute this is something
that's that's for me at least difficult
to understand as I see it it is it is
attempting to make a to to use
mathematics to prove something about the
background assumptions that uh in which
alignment is is situated what do you
think of this research Paradigm should
we have I mean is there any hope here so
I feel like both Paul and elieza with
stream if you put them in the same
bucket I think their research is
actually very different
um so just to say a few words on that
um the straw man I mean I'm specifically
straw Manning because Eliezer and Paul
are some of the most difficult people to
get their true opinions right so
basically every single person I know
completely mischaracterizes Paul even
people who know him very well like
whenever someone who knows the fall very
well I asked him what Paul believes they
tell me X and then I asked Paul he tells
me something different so like I I think
I don't think this is malicious I think
it's just
hit Paul and yukoski's opinions are very
subtle and very complex and
communicating them is hard so
I am pre-fractioning this I am
definitely misunderstanding what Paul
and Elias are truly believe I can just
give my best straw man so my best straw
man I can give for Cristiano view is
that he works on currently something
called elk which is eliciting latent
knowledge it's kind of like this attempt
to adapt plus another thing that I'm
aware is trying to like
think of worst case scenarios how can
you get like true knowledge out of like
neural networks how can you get their
true beliefs about system or not
necessarily networks like any system
like arbitrary system
even if they're deceptive and
also related to that he does some like
semi-formal work about like proofs and
like calls out causal tracing through
neural networks stuff like this I this
is a straw man this is definitely not an
accurate description but he actually
does but this is the closest I can get
while Eliezer
um well he's currently on Hiatus he's
currently on sabbatical so I don't think
he's currently doing any research
actually but historically what Miri
there in the organization that he
founded does is
kind of building formal models of agency
like trying to deconfuse agency and
Intelligence on a far more fundamental
level than building like you know just
doing some code and trying to build an
AI and then figuring out how to line it
it's way more thinking for first
principles
what is an agent what is optimization
what would it mean for systems to be
aligned or corrigible can we like
Express these things formally how can
like systems know that you know they or
their successes will be aligned how can
they prove things about themselves how
would they coordinate or like work
together a lot of work on like decision
theory on embedded agency and stuff like
this so I think a lot of the Miri
Paradigm is um
a lot more subtle than and then and I
understand the Murray Paradigm better
than I do Paul
um I think a lot of it is very subtle
but actually
I think a lot of the mirror work is very
good I think it's very good work I think
it's really interesting
um
but that's just my opinion
um so
when people talk about like formal
mathematical theories blah blah blah
they often refer I think to like
something that I think Eliezer said in
the sequences where he's like the only
way to get aligned AGI is like formally
proof checked full thing you know solve
all of alignment in theory and then you
know build API
I
don't know if he still believes this he
probably does but I'm just saying I just
don't know I haven't I don't think I've
asked him maybe I've asked him but I
don't remember his answer
um
and I don't think Paul believes this I
might I I like
Paul last time I talked to him again
this is straw man please don't hold me
for this Paul sorry if I'm misresenting
you here
um my understanding is that he has like
you know 30 P Doom even in on the
current path or something like that
which obviously isn't going through
formal methods so by that I deduce that
he doesn't expect this to be necessary
if that's wrong I apologize that's just
my impression that Paul is quite open to
non-formal things and neural networks
and that kind of stuff well you guys are
kind of has this belief that like if we
if it's just neural networks we're super
script we're just super super screwed
there's nothing we can do it's way too
hard so like
a lot of the muri perspective I think is
it like aligning neural networks is so
hard that we have to develop something
that is a neural networks that is easier
to align and they have to use that
instead and this has been not super
successful as far as I can tell my view
on this is
not sure about Paul's agenda
bit pessimistic I'm pretty pessimistic
about elk it seems too hard
um pretty pessimistic about that don't
really understand the other stuff he's
working on can't really comment on that
um I definitely disagree with him on
some points about interpretability and
um pedoom and such I think he's too
optimistic about many things but every
time when I bring this up he actually
then has good Counterpoint so maybe he
has some good counterpoints I just don't
know about
for Eliezer I agree that in a good world
that's what we would do like I think in
a good world where people are are sane
and like coordinated and we take lots of
time we would do much more meary like
things not necessarily exactly what Miri
did I think some of the exact details of
like emir's research identity are like
not what I would have done but like the
general like class of things like those
deconfused agency let's deconfuse
alignment courage ability and then like
try to build formal models and I try to
understand it I think this is super
sensible I think this is like a super
sensible thing to do it didn't work in
this one specific instance given the
constraints they had I don't think that
means the entire class of methodologies
you know ontologically flawed and like
cannot possibly work I'm just like you
know they tried they found some things
that I find interesting and other things
didn't work out like bro that's how
science works and perhaps perhaps it
could have worked if we had started in
1950 working on this and had developed
it alongside the you know the general
mathematics of computation or something
like that yep I think this is completely
feasible I think it's completely
possible just like things have gone
slightly differently or just you know if
Miri had you know one more John Von
Newman get involved and get really into
it in the early days like you know I
think it's not obvious that this is a
hundred years away or something like
this
um it might be but it's not obvious to
me like things always feel impossibly
far away until they're not people
thought you know flying machines were
hundreds of years away the day before it
happened same thing with like you know
nuclear fusion and like vision and like
stuff like that so like
it's I feel like Miri gets a bad rap
because that sure they made some
technical bets and they didn't quite
work out but I think that's like fair so
I'm pretty sympathetic to the utkowski
view even so I am
uh so my personal view is kind of like
we're at the point this is a strategic
decision like okay if I had if I knew I
had 50 years I would probably work on
mirror delay stuff but I'm like all
right I don't have 50 years so I'm like
the kind of Cohen stuff I work on is
more of a compromise between the various
positions well really all right there's
a spectrum between fully formal
everything white box and nothing formal
completely Black Box let's try to move
to as far towards the formal things
possible but no further kind of that
makes any sense it does so perhaps
introduce poems these cognitive
emulations yeah so uh cognitive
emulation or poem is the agenda that I
and projector are primer focused on
right now it is a proposal or for a well
more research agenda for how we could
get towards more
safe useful powerful AI systems by
fundamentally
trying to build bounded understandable
systems that emulate human-like
reasoning not arbitrary reasoning not
like they just solve the problem but
whatever means necessary but they solve
it in the way humans would solve a
problem in a way that you can understand
so when you use a co-em system and so
these are system top models like I don't
expect this to be like this on neural
network this is like a it may involve
neural networks it probably does involve
neural networks but it'll be like a you
know system of many sub components which
can include neural networks but also
include non-neural Network components
that
when you use such a system at the end
you get a causal story you get a reason
to believe that you can understand using
human-like reasoning why it made the
choices it did why it did the things it
did and why you should trust the output
to be valid in this regard
yeah and for listeners who were enticed
by that description they should go back
and listen to the previous podcast in
this series where Conan and me we
discussed this for an hour and a half
all right so as we see more and more
capable AI systems do you expect us to
also see more and more public attention
do you expect the public attention to to
kind of scale with with capabilities or
will public attention lag behind and
only come in right at the very end both
in that I think we're at the very end
and we're sorry to see the attention now
okay do you think that this will on net
be a positive or negative so will public
attention to AI make AI safer at the
current point I see it as
positive
um this is not obvious it could still go
negative very easily but the way I
currently see things is that all the
everyone is racing headlong into the
abyss and at least what the public so
far in my experience been able to do is
to notice hey wait what the don't
do that
which is great progress that's correctly
you can tell it is
truly imagining
how many smart you know ml professors
and whatever are so incredibly utterly
resistant to the possibility that what
they're doing might be bad or might be
the interest it is
incredible the level of rationalization
that people are capable of I mean it's
not incredible like it's actually very
expected this is exactly what you expect
they rely on a man to understand
something when a salary depends on him
not understanding it and even the people
who claim to understand it and say all
the right words like you know they still
do it like you know opening eye can say
all the nice words about alignment they
want or anthropic or deepind or whatever
they're still racing to AGI and they
don't have an alignment solution so
I don't like speculating about people's
like internal minds or like why are they
doing it are they good or are they
aligned or that I don't really care what
I care about is what they do and
for me the writing is on the wall just
people are just reading towards the
abyss and if no intervention happens if
nothing changes they will just go
straight off that Cliff with all of us
in tile and I think the public
you know even so they don't understand
many things and there's many ways in
which they can make things worse do seem
to understand the very very simple
concept of don't Korean off Abyss into
the abyss
stop that right now so here's an
argument uh open AI releases gbt4 and
this draws a lot of attention and
therefore we get more resource sources
into regulation and and AI Safety
Research and so on and so it's actually
a good thing to release a model that's
that's very capable but not a super
intelligent AGI is this is this a Galaxy
brain is this 4D chess or do you think
there's something there sure there's
something there but it is also just
obviously for DHS like it's like okay
if you had a theory with which you could
predict where the abyss is
sure okay
there is no such Theory you have no idea
what these systems can do when people
get their hands on you have no idea what
happens when you augment them with tools
or whatever you have no idea what these
things can do there's no bounds there's
no limits or whatever so every time you
release a model every time you build
such a model you're rolling your die you
know maybe this time's fine maybe next
time's fine but at some point it won't
be like it's Russian Roulette sure you
know you can you can play some Russian
Roulette most of the time it's fine you
know five out of six people say Russian
Roulette is fine what about a possible
counterproductive overreactions from
more public attention to AI for example
imagine that we decide to pause AI
research but AI Safety Research gets
lumped in with AI capabilities research
and so even though we're not making any
progress on capabilities we're not
making any progress on safety either and
when we lift this pause we are in the
same place as when we instigated it
honestly I'd be extremely surprised if
that happened like I'm trying to imagine
how that would actually play out in the
real world like people won't even accept
like a moratorium on training things
larger than gpt4 which is like the
easiest thing to implement the easiest
thing to monitor that affects like you
know a teeny tiny sliver of all AIS
research like there are so few people
that could or ever would train a gp4
size model and
you know that's such a teeny tiny sliver
of AI research and not even that is like
feasible in the current political world
it's like very hard to get done it's
like an overreach so large that you know
Mary doodling you know type theory on
their whiteboards get shut down I'm like
oh
that's a not the world we live in like
if we were in that world I would be like
okay interesting
um let's talk about it but this is just
not the world we live in
what about AI becoming a military
technology and only the only military
can work on it and perhaps they work on
it in ways that uh turn out to be
dangerous yep I am concerned about this
I think this is one of the ways things
can go really badly
um I used to be more virulently against
this than I am now
now in another sense I look at where
we're currently heading and I'm like all
right currently we have a hundred
percent Doom chance
what are the other options right and so
look I'm not going to defend like many
of the atrocity is committed by
militaries across the world or whatever
right I'm not going to say that there's
not problems here I'm not going to like
say deny that there's some really
up people involved in these in these
organizations or anything like that of
course there are but also
um at least in the Democratic West you
know don't want to speak about other
nations but like there is such a thing
is oversight like there are Court
martialings like this is an actual thing
actually happens in a sense the military
is authoritarian in a good way like the
the military is very authoritarian there
is hierarchy there is Authority there's
accountability there is structure like
very like the US military does a lot of
bad things but at least to some degree
they are accountable to the American
public like not perfectly there's lots
of problems here but like if a senator
wants a hearing to investigate something
going on in the military they can
usually get it which you know is not
perfect
you know huge problems or whatever but
I'm like
that's something and like people
do you look like you know politicians do
care you know
um they might make very stupid mistakes
and they might make stupid things and it
might make things worse like the dod
could scale up you know like you know
gbt4 very easily they could make
something much bigger than that you know
if they if they did a Manhattan Project
and they you know put all the money
together to create you know GPT you know
you know gptf you know just like end of
the world system then they they could
and that would be bad
um so I think it can make it worse but
it's not obviously so it's not like it
could also be that they you know a like
also it's just like super competent slow
you know bureaucratic mess and the
military is very conservative
like very very conservative about what
they deploy what we'll do they want
extremely high levels of security they
want extremely high levels of
reliability before they use anything
like if we built AI systems to military
standards of like reliability like like
the military requested that like every
AI system is like you know as reliable
as a flight control system I would be
like well that's not great like
uh that sounds awesome of course that is
a Rosy view like probably
when I think it's not a question it's
military gets evolved I think it's a
question of when and
when this happens it probably has the
law of undignified failure goes if a
thing can fail it will always fail in
the least dignified way possible so
probably it won't get to this level but
I think we should not dismiss out of
hand that I mean first of all I think
it's ridiculous to accept that the
military will not get involved I think
this is just
impossible at this point unless we get
you know paper clip tomorrow like on
things unless things go so fast that no
one can react military will get involved
and we should work with them we should
be there to like be like all right how
can we help the military handle this as
non-stupidly as possible and I do think
that a lot of people that work in a
military do care and would like things
to be safe and work well
so
is it worse than you know Sam Altman you
know all like Doctor Strange Love style
you know is running you know things as
fast as possible is it worse if you know
the military nationalizes the whole
thing and grinds into this bureaucratic
monstrosity not obvious to me I'm not
saying I know obviously it is good but
it's not obviously not good all right
gonna thank you for coming on the
podcast pleasure zoeys